m le soleil et de la musique un cocktail
parfait pour danser mais surtout pour
manifester
en ce jour de sommet de la société
civile une journée organisée en marge du
sommet de la terre on veut faire passer
des messages au dissident à la demande
des gars me demande que les dirigeants
se prennent en main et agissent comme
s'il y avait une crise urgente parce que
nous vivons une crise urgente et
l'approbation du projet canadien baie du
nord fait aussi réagir satchmo c'est un
réel bourbier comment est ce possible en
2022 puis au micro cette militante de la
namibie dénoncé activités de la
compagnie canadienne mais qu en afrique
à qui veut extraire du pétrole et du gaz
dans son pays
inna mari ashiq angot était aussi éviter
comme conférencière à un événement
organisé du traité de non prolifération
des combustibles fossiles une initiative
internationale pour l'abandon des
combustibles fossiles et le soutien à
une transition juste la militante ne
rate aucune occasion de faire passer son
message car elle craint que le projet de
l'entreprise canadienne détruisent une
grande réserve écologique essentiel à la
survie de ses concitoyens de vraiment
l'exploitation de nos terres de nos
peuples et aussi de notre culture
continue colonialisme le pétrole et le
gaz extraits seront destinés au marché
canadien selon l'activiste l'entreprise
manque de transparence et use de moyens
douteux pour arriver à ses fins c'est
très très très difficile de se combattre
contre ce boîte parce que ils utilisent
les moyens comme l'argent et les les
affinités avec les politiciens amis bien
et on ne peut pas se défendre c'est pour
ça que nous sommes ici il ya sept
challenger pour la présidente du traité
le canada a un devoir de réserve
une position que partage inna mari ashiq
angot et moi je reviens demandé à
monsieur trudeau
qui se nomme champion de le climat
comment ça se fait que
il n'intervient pas du tout le canada a
déjà une histoire de colo nalisation et
envers les peuples indigènes les
demandes sont nombreuses le ton est
pressante d'autant plus qu'elle avait du
sommet de la terre aux craint que les
pays du g20 instrumentalise la guerre en
ukraine pour justifier une plus grande
production de pétrole et de gaz ici et
les à céret radio-canada stockholm